العربيه ببدء اجتماع العقبه بين كبار
المسؤولين الامريكيين والسياسيين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بمشاركه
امريكيه مصريه المباحثات ستشمل ملفات
سياسيه وامنيه وعسكريه وذلك بهدف وقف موجه
العنفله اندلعت خلال الاشهر الاخيره واضاف
المسؤولون الاجتماع سيعقد ليوم واحد في
ميناء العقبه على البحر الاحمر بحضور
مبعوث الرئيس الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط
كما سيجتمع كبار قاده الامن الاسرائيليين
وفلسطينيين للمره الاولى منذ عده سنوات
بالاضافه الى ممثلين عن اطراف سياسيه بل
اطراف الرئيسيه في المنطقه في المقابل
المشاهدين استنكرت فصائر فلسطينيه مشاركه
وفد من السلطه في الاجتماع قالت انه
استكمالا لما وصفته بمخططات التامر على
الشعب
هذا وكشف تقرير صحفي اسرائيلي ان رئيسي
جهاز الامن العام شباك سيشارك في القمه
الامنيه المقرر انطلاقها في العقبه
بالاردن وقال موقع والا انبار سينضم للوفد
الاسرائيلي المكون من مستشار الامن القومي
صحيحا بي ومدير عام وزاره الخارجيه
الحكومي في المناطق الفلسطينيه اللواء
الاسرائيلي غسان عليان ان مشاركه البار
تدل على الاهميه التي يليها الشابات لوقف
التصعيد الامني في الضفه الغربيه حتى لا
يتحول الى انتفاضه جديده